Okay.
So now let's tackle
objective three together.
This objective really has three parts.
First we need to create a link
to make a new restaurant.
Then create a page to handle the get
request when we click on that link.
And finally, a get post method to
persist the data to the database.
Well the first part
doesn't seem too hard.
Let's add another anchor tag to our
restaurants page that prompts the user
to create a new restaurant,
followed by a few break lines.
We can go ahead and
fill out this href to /restaurants/new
as stated in the objective.
Next, I will create another page to
handle this new restaurant request.
Inside my do_GET block, I will add
another if statement that looks for
the /restaurants/new URL.
Looking at this code,
we can see a lot of similarities with
our previous do_GET if statements.
I have added here a field where the user
can input the name of a new restaurant.
So now that the layout is in place,
the magic really happens
with our post request.
Unlike get requests,
post requests cannot be executed by
simply typing a URL in the browser and
hitting enter.
However, do_POST is going to look for
the /restaurants /newpath,
passed along from my forum,
in order to know what action to perform.
Inside my do_POST,
I will comment out the previous
code inside the try block for now.
I then add an if statement,
looking for /restaurants/new.
Then I extract the information from
the form similarly to the way I
did it in the first web server we wrote.
But this time I incorporate that
data into my declaration of
a new restaurant class.
Also differently now,
instead of printing my results to
the current webpage, I create a redirect
here that will take me back to my
original restaurant's homepage.
Let's save and restart our server again.
If we can create a new restaurant, and
see it added to our page,
objective three is over and out.
The source code for objective three
is available in the instructor notes.